hi I'm young Pegg and I'm going to be
reading you guys best friend
Dugger why yourself for life [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] you your mom and everything else
the person going I know is that guy oh
my him too by the way free to go that's
my best friend that's my best friend
flexing big old booty bitche message
from Texas was Nixon I'm a skeet off
little [ __ ] come catch me catch me and
that's my bestie my bestie my best
friend go best friend [ __ ] living ttg
and everything is still on fleek but
yeah right batteries rolling with me
she's gonna smile cuz she's on fleet
hundred thousand dollars inside my pants
my shits on fleek yeah take them boys to
school
swagger number three [ __ ] I'm bleeding
bad like a bumble bee hello hello oh
look [ __ ] Pro see i'ma eat that booty
July groceries you don't have cootie
later [ __ ] down like let's do it no
tiger [ __ ] eat that we'll eat that
would supply I supply a [ __ ] I got
Pistons in the would I want tacos out of
Megan good helicopter chopping with the
birds stuffing rats inside of me peanuts
being that other side [ __ ] cuff yeah
and miry first louder than a speaker
yeah my niece is hanging with the
Beatles if you ever find there better
keeper who wrote it
that I almost knew everything 37 counts
for the sneakers going out like ox or
beanie sigel
sitting a cop I can't wait to mistreat
them forcing your whole I can't wait
them as lead them and beat them they my
people that's my best friend that's my
best friend
you